all right Steven see the duggar upgrade
from Persia that's Tuesday awesome
right up side with Franklin Franklin
Midway she little place in Massachusetts
and you grew up with both cats yeah
talk about your chocolate chocolate I
mean they got stuff go to school they're
like 7th or 8th grade
I guess you get over one so you were in
high school
no no not at all I think that way to uh
two days maybe and where'd you let's go
from there
was pretty Street you know to me so to
the streets meaning what
thank you buddy self to the streets kind
of sometimes we got on the water stay
yeah period are you doing drugs business
yeah crack cocaine
okay what's your own today hey Lou Chris
how's it go you could try the wall man
what do you do for Mike oops
yeah just some stores you know right
[Music]
and you kids in Europe yeah
I think you have to say [ __ ] thank you
Stu
get two kids yeah
one lived in Texas when the to make
excuses here we're talking
[Music]
did you ever talk to them kids I know
[Music]
where do you stay down you're still
around Street pilgrim we can do ten oh
yeah definitely
yeah and how long you been down here how
many years
it's 2012
so seven years yeah yeah and if you've
ever been beat down roughed up take
advantage of like that no more people
Boyet and start playing with it I'm
sorry more people I think would avoid it
in tristar if I okay alright so you bear
okay yeah I mean they think to academy
bro
and they prove that your friends are
dear friends are ya yeah but they feel
really fresh here I mean it's the ones
that live uptown Osteen sleeping bags
and little groups city I don't know but
you're asleep huh
what you got up your sleeve yeah I know
no I'm gonna do some things going on
tonight
so sure right it's probably is necessary
to go game come on Tim all right keep
foodies Abel show everything thank you
thank you